margate was among 101 towns from across
england selected a bid for funding from
the government's towns fund initiative
this is a once-in-a-generation
opportunity to invest in local projects
drive growth and improve the environment
for the benefit of the whole community
the town deal comes at an important and
exciting time in margate's history
the town has faced its challenges over
the last 50 years
and now is the time to come together to
make sure it has a thriving economy
365 days a year
at the heart of the town deal is the
town investment plan which sets out a
long-term vision and strategy for
margate
the investment plan makes the case for a
29 million pound investment
supporting projects themed around four
interlinking interventions
these build on what makes margate so
special and deliver change that will
benefit local people
and visitors for years to come margate's
growing creative and cultural economy is
an opportunity not to be missed
the first intervention is therefore a
nine million pound investment in scaling
margate's creative production and skills
it will establish a creative land trust
to support projects stretching from the
high street
to the theatre royal building spaces for
creative production and education
potential locations include the former
marks and spencers
primark and other key sites within the
high street
investment will bring life back to the
town centre linking the coast to the
historic hawley square
and establishing a creative economic hub
driving jobs
skills education and engagement
in its heyday margate was known as a
place for well-being and tourism
the second intervention is a 6.5 million
pound investment in coastal well-being
to support projects across margate's
coastline creating new and surprising
experiences for visitors
establishing better links between the
town centre north down road and the
coastline
will deliver an improved network of
connections and encourage people to
explore
beyond the seafront the third
intervention focuses on public realm and
connections
with a 4.5 million pound targeted
investment in the town centre
coastline and residential areas making
it easier to get around
and improving visitor amenities this
will better connect north down road to
the town centre
and create attractive public spaces as
well as enhancing cycling
and walking infrastructure margate's
past has a role to play in its future
the fourth intervention is therefore a
nine million pound investment
in well-loved heritage assets and will
help secure a sustainable future for the
dreamland cinema complex and the winter
gardens
which benefits the wider town it will
create new enterprise and cultural
spaces for both visitors and the
community
it will also support the development of
feasibility plans for the future of
important landmarks including the
arlington arcade
the old town hall and the lido the town
investment plan has now been submitted
to the ministry of housing communities
and local government
thank you to everyone who took the time
to get involved and share their views
we're currently waiting to hear back
from the government and in the meantime
the town deal board and project team
continue to work in partnership with
stakeholders local businesses
and the community you can read the tan
investment plan in full
keep up to date with how the deal
progresses and sign up to receive news
at margate dot towndeal.co.uk